was bisher geschah ich habe 2010 10 12
[Musik]
fast schon wieder frostschutz gefunden
auf diese sekte und damit viel spaß mit
dem zweiten teil des märchens von der
orange grün mutter und ihrem kind
richtig
ich habe nicht das kind oder wobei
wahrscheinlich schon das war rein von
der optik her will ich sagen kann ja
sein aber die optik ist ja auch nicht so
naturbelassen
das ist kein natürlicher haut
das ist der punkt auf dem diese folge in
eine ganz falsche richtung geht okay
wenn du bist du okay wenn du nur sechs
jahren cola gehen willst meinetwegen das
ist dein kind aber du kannst das
sechsjährige nicht sagen dass ich mit
dem popo wackeln soll und der jury zu
gefallen
ein zeichen hat weder teuer lässt sich
etwas einfallen die mahlzeit beihilfe
deswegen claussen der vor gericht geld
also mir falls ich nicht wusste dass das
hilft mir und das wird halt immer geld
geklaut
[Musik]
sparkassen die sparkassen gelten
köln bonn
warum spielst du was immer in köln
eltern wissen auch dass in köln leute
ist es ein seltsames gefühl mit so
gefühlt allen hilft mir produktionen und
darstellen einer stadt zu sein
locker 50 prozent von den menschen die
wir da so verarschen wurden einfach
gehen unsere stadt
und für mir ist nichts zu teuer jasmin
greift zu und fällt die unterschrift
ihres freundes das habe der klasse kann
also irgendwelche etwas kriminelles was
passiert da kommen wir wieder auf das
thema zurück leute jungen menschen in
deutschland muss der richtige weg
gezeigt werden ihr habt geld mit ihren
fast 30.000 euro für die einrad schule
ihrer tochter zahlen sodass kein job
oder sehbehindert klappt doch einfach
fisch unterschriftenfälschung diebstahl
meinetwegen raum aber nicht arbeit was
soll das das geht überhaupt nicht jasmin
macht sich hier ganz klar strafbar wenn
ich so was wir da nicht vor dem
greenscreen sitzen soll etwas glücklich
gesehen konnte jetzt haben sie sogar
zweimal am start recht auch für alle die
weltweit bei den begriff sich denken
würde dass wir zu viel
euro zeichnen weil an meinen hätte ja
auch ein paar davon zeichnet machen
können einen tag später das casting von
mir steht kurz bevor jasmin hat ihre
spieluhr für 130 euro bei einem
pfandleiher verkaufen können ich spiele
nur damit kann sie auf jeden fall die
dvd für ihre tochter kaufen doch es
fehlen immer noch 70 euro für die
klassenfahrt haben sich jasmins teure
investitionen gelohnt
nein was ja ja das ist eine echte narren
los angeles ein echter selbst sicherlich
ein bisschen abgeschnitten und sich am
kopf die zukunft ist er ganz bestimmt
hier passen
ich stehe also da ich hätte so viel
liter bier gedanke kämpft so damit die
balance ist seiten wird bester dax wert
das ding ist ganz wichtig man einfach
die kreolen aussehen und die damit
machen lassen das ist dann halt auch
immer freundlich
diese urige basketball sowie gemeinter
er schon verbuchen
bist du denn was machst du hast du lust
hast mich zu zeigen
er gibt mir ein bisschen krieg wie weit
muss man so hat mia leblos und mama
jasmin ist überglücklich
30 minuten später die jury hat sich
entschieden der scout der werbefirma
gibt die sieger distanz castings bekannt
ich glaube es werden in verschiedenen
altersklassen menschen gesucht
wenn wir so zwei diesen 18 war 2010 die
da drüben die mutter der kinder gar
nicht dabei
und dann haben wir eine sechsjährige bei
den verschiedenen altersklassen heute so
müssen einfach noch alle nehmen die
daten um dort die mutter selber vier
leute entschieden die gegen die siegerin
von den genannten schulen antreten wird
und einen weiteren casting
sagen ja das ist ja wie prada miu sieht
acting mal wieder dass in holland
das war eine stunde später
jasmin ist verzweifelt die kosten
wachsen ihr deutlich über den kopf und
jetzt kommen noch die reisekosten zum
großen casting in holland dazu gesagt
verstehe das problem ist weil hat doch
genug menschen die an vertrauen in der
familie und beklagen kann und will doch
viel zu teuer
ich habe mal wieder den dringenden
verdacht dass sie sich bei dieser
anzeige auf dem laptop um foto handelt
das ist wieder ein foto hinter dem
kühlschrank genommen und screenshot oben
ist keine url brillant aber sie komme
jetzt dieses risiko ist so viel zu teuer
jeder kämpfer hat schon über separate
sehen will dann muss man halt nochmal
und tastatur auch klar die us minister
bereits alles durchgegangen
hier steht das wasser bis zum hals sie
sieht nur noch eine lösung um an das
geld für die holland reise und die
klassenfahrt zu kommen 558 euro
verkaufen
handys laptop im wandel
bereits zwei stunden später hat jasmin
das laptop für 310 euro an ein elektro
gebraucht fachhandel verkauft
das letzte davon kann sie auf jeden fall
die reise nach holland bezahlen
schließlich hat heute gegen deinen will
dann ist jetzt halt dein maul jasmin
projiziert ihre erwartungen und wünsche
auf mir schlimmer wenn ich mir die
signale ihrer tochter die eigentlich was
ganz anderes
[Musik]